some aleikum my name is Salim Ahmed
image I will be the guest on the Deen
show telling you about my life in don't
get go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
Salam alaikum peace be with you I'm
Eddie your host of the Deen show and
this week oh man you are gonna be amazed
this is an incredible human an
incredible human being that you're gonna
meet an amazing person son L got a
chance to spend a little bit of time
with them
we got his interview and this will help
all of us who complain
we just complain and day and night when
you look at this brothers situation and
how buoyant and happy he is how he's
passing his test and he doesn't have
many of the things that we have and
you're gonna get to see that firsthand
when we come back here in the den show
now just before we cut out and go to
this week's show just a friendly
reminder for myself first and foremost
and for all the millions of viewers that
are out there it's Ramadan we need to
get the most out of it hum did Allah all
praises to the credit of heavens and
earth has given us life that we can
experience another Ramadan so this is a
training ground we want to develop
ourselves that's right to be the best
human beings that we can be so we gotta
watch out for all the evil things that
will not be conducive to the development
of our spiritual side our taqwa our God
consciousness developing ourselves so we
can get and have a closer relationship
with our Creator this is what the plan
is this is what we need to be doing so
then we'll have a boost
we'll get pumped up and we'll be ready
for the rest of the year and if the law
gives us life and be back at it again
because the iman goes up and down and
this is the time to all the extra acts
of worship to really refrain from every
evil vice that's out there it's tough
it's not easy but you know what as you
go higher up you want to get that PhD
you want to get that doctorate there's
less people in class isn't there so the
higher you are in developing yourself
you know what it's going to take a
little more
patience is gonna take a little more
commitment but along those you can do it
so he wants to bring out the best in you
so you can have the higher levels agenda
that's right we want to get to paradise
this life is short it's gonna end at any
time so the reminder is especially
during this month we have to be cautious
about all the bad things that are out
there and you know what some of those
things now are the gossiping the
backbiting getting in other people's
business saying things about people as
the Prophet peace be upon him said to
say something that your brother wouldn't
like when he's not in front of you when
his presence is not there as backbiting
but then to say something about her or
him that's not true that slander so we
have to be careful have our tongue moist
moist with the remembrance of a law of
the create or not with things that are
of no benefit that the angel on the
right he's not writing down the good
he's writing down the bad and another
thing we have to be aware of so if we
train ourselves and now is going to be
easier for the rest of the year when we
get out of Ramadan this is the training
ground you know it I'm just reminding
you and myself and another thing we have
to stay away from there's a lot of good
that can be accomplished with a lot of
the social media tools that are out
there so I don't want to just speak
generally I want to give you something
tangible to work on you know we get
taken away with a lot of the
technological advances and Facebook is
one of them millions of people got it
and we're on there chatting away
we're chatting await a lot of times
we're chatting away with useless chit
chat er jibber jabber and you know what
is the angel on the right is he writing
the good deeds
what are we doing are we refraining from
things that we should be refraining from
are we getting into you know it starts
off with the innocent hello how are you
you expose yourself and now what happens
now you end up talking to the opposite
gender without your parents permission
the women especially strike a pose and
now everybody's like hey you looking so
fine there honey
and what happens now your head gets a
little big and now what happens you'll
full of yourself and what happens now
it's harder to disattach from this
you're liking the attention but is this
pleasing to Allah is the attention of
all the boys out there more pleasing
than the attention of Allah
same thing for the young men out there
you're posting all the pictures
maybe if women that shouldn't be on your
page you're exposing yourself and your
body your aura you're exposing your body
and you're putting things out there that
wow we can't believe as Muslims that
these things are up on your accounts man
you need to chill especially during this
month we need to refrain we are Muslims
sisters brothers please now is the time
get away from the useless jibber-jabber
chit chatter don't expose yourselves out
there the wolves are on the hunt and
they're looking to get those good
sisters they're out there and same thing
for the brothers don't get caught off
guard you see something that's like
arrow through the heart and now your
iman what does it increase no it
decreases and you're looking for looking
at things you shouldn't be looking at
you should be lowering the gaze you
should be staying away from these things
but you know what we get tricked we get
trapped because shakedowns the pimp he's
the biggest pimp and he's looking a pimp
us so please now is the time to refrain
from all the evil things sisters of this
month you've got a chance to observe the
hijab don't take it off at the end of
Ramadan don't turn the corner and put
the tight jeans on when nobody's looking
don't do that these are tangible things
these are real things in the real world
that we're facing the issues brother
you're in the Masjid you ain't swearing
Ackerson but you turn the corner and
you're speaking French and I'm not
talking French frys of French food I'm
talking about the foul language that's
coming out of your mouth so these are
just a few things that we need to be
aware of where Muslims were once we're
consciously submitted - whoo - a man - a
monkey nam we've submitted to the one
who's created this whole universe and
everything in it and he's got a great
reward for us he's got a great prize as
the ultimate prize of Jenna get your
eyes hypnotized to that prize stay away
many of the r-rated movies and is from a
dying you refraining from what from food
and drink but now you're watching the
big screen
you're flickering through the channels
and promiscuity and women naked and men
naked and they kiss in an American Idol
and again you're losing your fast you
don't even know what you're starving
yourself but you know what it's all
going out the window because again we're
not watching what we should not be
watching and that's the reminder that I
want to remind myself and my brothers
and sisters out of the love uh that we
love you here at the Deen show so please
these are some practical things that are
going on so if you find yourself your
iman is going down check yourself you
got some CD or some music in the car
bobbing your head to fifty cents or Lady
Gaga googoo and all that other nonsense
these are these are the things that do
not help us or bring us closer to the
crater the heavens and earth they don't
remind us about paradise that they're
judgment the Hereafter doing good they
take us away from doing good
and we end up falling into trickery we
end up falling into things that decrease
our email please this is the advice that
I give you especially during this month
that we strengthen up our cells we walk
straight we proud to be Muslims once
again who has submitted to the will of
the one god acquiring piece by doing all
the good things that he's told us to do
the same way Jesus Moses all the
righteous predecessors all of them did
this and the last and final messenger
sent to mankind his Sunnah is the way
that we need to follow and we need to
this month really get to know it tune in
to the Deen show tune into PST who did
there's so many other media outlets stay
away from the things that will only
hinder you from growing in the Deen from
growing in your relationship with the
one who created you but will only
decrease you and you know what def hits
you and you die in a bad state and as
allah says the crater says do not die
except in a state of full submission so
when you chatting away and you're
looking at something that you're not
supposed to be looking at you're doing
some things you're not supposed to be
doing
you know what they are ask yourself is a
lot please with me at this moment am i
earning his pleasure or you know what
I'm getting closer to the fire
oh Allah please protect us from this
please protect us from this and grant us
your Janina grant us your Jin now let's
be more in a constant state of
self-development according to how the
Creator Allah the Almighty has told us
to be that's worshiping him alone
following the Sunnah of the last and
final messenger sent to mankind the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him the
same way you would have been following
Jesus Moses and all the messengers if
you were living during their time and
this was the reminder to myself first
and foremost and to all my brothers and
sisters and humanity and my brothers and
sisters in his faith I love you for the
sake of Allah keep me and all of us at
the deanship in your duas let's go on to
meet brother Sanel son el an amazing and
amazing individual you'll see in a
moment when we come back peace
[Music]
is his messenger Allah
ha there's only one bed and Jesus was
his messenger Allah why did that maybe
ice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the Dean show this is your
horse today a new face
this is dr. Mandir Mohammed welcoming
you to a wonderful unique program today
today I am interviewing a new person a
person that whom you will love whenever
you see on this screen and you will be
proud of a person that I felt so proud
of meeting him today I came to Chicago
today and I was lucky that brother Eddie
the host of this program the original
host of this program asked me to
interview this brother I've been here in
Chicago only for a few hours and I was
lucky to have this opportunity to meet
this brother called
sanim let me he let him introduce
himself to you and let's hear from how
he wants to introduce himself so like my
name is Salim Ismail the beach I'm 13
years old I'm from Bosnia Herzegovina
and I live in Chicago Illinois and let's
face it my information okay and you love
to live in Chicago yes and I think
everybody lives in Chicago
loves to cattle very much why do you
think that GK was better than other
places because it's more diverse and why
do you like do you like diversity yes
and there's a lot of Muslims here yes do
you interact with them the Muslims yes
my friends are Muslim and for example
like my friends that come from different
countries to our muscle oh you have
friends from different countries let her
also to say there's a Muslim still yeah
okay good that's good I'm glad to hear
that tell me I see that you speak
English and do you speak other languages
I speak sign language you speak sign
language English Bosnian a little bit of
Spanish a little bit of Spanish yes Wow
so four languages yeah that's you are
much better than my
you know all these languages and 1/2
hamdullah do you think good for that yes
so now you know few languages you know
sign language how did you learn the sign
language um from my parents because
they're both deaf and I picked it off I
picked up words and letters as I grow
older your two parents are deaf yes they
don't listen
yeah and you'll learn from them sign
language yes and now you are using this
language to communicate with them yes
and you're making life much easier for
them by communicate in fact it was very
difficult for me and for brother Eddie
to communicate with your father until
you came and we found that you are
helping us a lot do you think a lost
planet Allah for this or do you think
your parents for this I think both of
them because I let's find what I like
gave me the chance of learning something
that other people wouldn't have yeah and
I don't have it myself I don't have I
have a handicapped child and I could not
learn sign language I could could not
communicate with them so I think you are
list humble Allah so Allah glorified you
and blessed you with this ability to
help your two parents you're doing a
wonderful job although you are young you
are handicapped but you're doing a
wonderful job that I'm quite sure sha
Allah Allah is so pleased with you right
are you pleased with Allah yes okay why
are you pleased for that because he made
my life easier and a lot more like
exciting and more like educational where
did you get so you can learn as though
you're handicapped you still have some
blessings and bounties from Almighty
Allah that you can learn and you can
communicate and not only one language if
you're talking about four languages that
works smoothly wonderful you're English
amazing it's better than my English yes
and I'm really proud of you now let me
tell me ask you
I've seen some tournament of these
wonderful things that tell me about that
um well these are in the trophies I'm
one that honor return events that I
played with buddy baseball witches you
do play baseball
yes which should embody baseball's which
like baseball for kids who are
handicapped okay and so I won this you
won this with my school so if your
school so it's it's a team work yes okay
and tell me about your role in the team
ah were you leading the team or were you
were just a member or a player I was
probably both cuz horse everybody was a
leader okay what they where they played
like I was the usually the UM the
picture or the yeah and so yeah so
everybody had different parts and roles
and tried their best to leave and you
were proud of yourself as you did that
and your parents are proud of you and
I'm proud well I'm quite sure that Allah
so Allah Tala loves to see you achieving
these things because Allah Spartan says
that I I have perhaps taken some of the
bounties and the blessings that I have
given to others to test them and
hamdulillah it's quite obvious that you
are in the process of passing the test
we ask Allah to give you support to
continue passing the test and achieve
more okay now I'd like to ask you tell
me about your future I've seen other
things also you achieved other things
would you like to tell me about this
thing also as well it's not the same it
is the same one but it was a little
older than the other one we just showed
you okay it was my first year this one
everybody raised ball so okay how long
have you been practicing this I don't
say about four years four years so so
you been practicing baseball since you
were nine years or
yes Oh amazing amazing
so although you are handicapped but this
did not prevent you from enjoying your
life tell me how do you spend most of
your time um well I need you do you need
different types of books or specific
types of books just anything that
anything that's all okay
and the Internet
oh you access to have access to the
Internet and you use the Internet
yes and you use your left hand yes and
you're comfortable with that uh-huh and
tell me what what do you like and
Internet um I like anybody here you go
okay I do
the games are large videos good my email
your email yeah respond with other
people by email
okay this wonderful opportunity here
let's take a break and come back one God
wishes him alone do what he wants you to
do
put your desire is this thing inside you
that just wants this and wants that and
you just can't get enough you know what
you'll never get enough until the dirts
in your mouth don't let it come to that
be sincere and honest ask the one who
created you to guide reach the first
step put off chasing all the women and
the good times and the parties and this
and that there is no one would be a
voice ship except Allah don't wait you
never know if that would come today for
you
[Music]
[Music]
I am Not Afraid alone this is your
hostage Elmendorf mohammed welcome to
the Deen show welcome to this unique
episode that's so unique in our life in
my life because I have a handicapped
child and in the life of every Muslim
let's hear from him now we've heard from
him that he is enjoying his life he has
a lot of readings he's a lot of hobbies
and he got some trophies because of his
hunger 'la practicing sports with other
people that would suit him so well no
he's disabled this did not prevent him
from practicing a normal life almost
close to normal but tell me about your
relationship with Allah with God ah you
are in a situation not like you are not
like in regular or any normal human
being you are handicapped tell me about
your experience does this affect your
relationship with God do you thank him
do you still thank him do you feel that
something new what is this how can you
describe your relationship with God
well I think I was one ha for giving me
everything and even um like for me being
disabled it's not really like something
that I hate because I get to learn
things about being disabled and like and
I still have a great relationship the
Lost Planet oh you still you still love
him
yes okay and you still do you pray and
the daily player yeah I try as hard as I
can
masha'Allah masha'Allah masha'Allah I
think I want every viewer to learn from
this he is disabled as you see they
still praise how about those people who
are blessed with their full bodies I
want them to listen
[Music]
[Music]
I have to
the world
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry for that perhaps you've seen
that I'm so touched by the words that
come from his heart and I envy him of
doing this I ask Allah subhana Allah to
give him support we see in the world
millions of people if not millions of
people who enjoy their full body however
they still they are thankful to their
Creator they are not thankful to the God
who created them with full and strong
body
let's enjoy talking through this
wonderful brother now you have some few
minutes now to talk to the whole world
what would you like what is the message
that you think because you have a unique
experience and you say that you enjoy
your life even if you are disabled what
is the message that you want to give to
the viewers there are millions of people
are watching unit so what would you like
to tell them I would like to tell them
to enjoy their life be thankful too I'm
offering whatever you have thankful of a
lot of whatever you have and whatever
you don't cuz even whatever you dog why
is that good like oh maybe he doesn't
give you bad things so we think though
he doesn't yeah
so Allah does not give you any bad thing
yes but he may be testing you sir this
is part of the test that you are every
human being is going through a test but
the test is different one of them may be
handicapped the other one may be sick
the other one may be deprived of
children the other one would be his
intellect would be less than the
intellect of others is not smart as you
you are smarter than many people that I
interviewed in my lifetime so Allah is
testing everybody with a different test
and now what a Muslim should do when he
or she is confronting a test should we
accept the test or should we reject it
and become ungrateful to Almighty Allah
we should accept and be thankful to our
last part for testing us and try your
hardest to do like whatever you can to
be thankful
happy and try to pass the test
masha'Allah masha'Allah and now we are
talking about tests and passing the test
do you believe that if you pass the test
successfully in this life there is
another later life do you believe in
that yes and do you believe that in that
life you will be given all the powers
that any other human being will have and
you are hoping for that yes you see and
is this a beauty of this religion that
you feel hopeful yeah cuz you know that
you may have already like now but better
you know they have the afterlife but if
you go to paradise okay no I am your
interviewer and older than you perhaps
three or four times if you want to give
me an advice for me what would you tell
me to never like give up and always be
happy never give up yeah I'll always be
happy yes thank you for this advice and
yeah we will try to wrap up very quickly
and we'll take a break and then we come
back after taking this break no problem
you can take my daughter to dinner you
and my daughter and me let me tell you
something it's natural
that's the idea that created and he
created us to have a good time we should
have a good time
only without wise though Islam is the
fastest growing religion in the world
and most of the converts are women not
men they see that the rules of Islam
instead of constraining it the rules set
them free
welcome back to the Dean show this is
your host dr. wonderful Howard Muhammad
interviewing well son oh yes again I
think that you need to remember sun'll
all the time because he's an example a
wonderful example that we rarely see
such an example in our life nowadays
particularly for those who are disabled
and I mentioned in the beginning that I
have one son who is disabled and I wish
that he would see what's going on
although he cannot communicate but I'm
quite sure that he will benefit from
this all the disabled people would see
how cheerful here is and how hopeful he
is and he still have some plans for the
future and I wish everybody would learn
from him not only the disabled but the
abled one and I'm going to come back to
them but let me ask him first tell me
about your future your dreams what do
you want to achieve what do you want to
happen what if you ask God now first
let's ask you if you ask God now what
you ask God to give you and so are like
better education knowledge of this song
so I like to become anything a medical
field the medical field to give you
support this this is not difficult for
other why this is so easy for Allah if
Allah wills he will give you health and
he will give you your body back and we
ask Allah Spano dollar to give you this
and I trust Allah and perhaps you have
heard the story of the Prophet a youth
he was so sick to the degree that his
family members used to carry him yes she
could not move at all he threw the
degree that he lost his skin and he was
in a terrible situation and allah
subhanaw taala love them then after
sometime when he passed the test
a lost planet Allah gave him his body
back and all his powers came back to him
so it's not difficult it's it's we just
continue asking Almighty Allah that he
will give you this in Java but tell me
about your future what do you want to do
after 20
years after 10 years what do you want in
your intro become something in the
medical field and the medical field you
want to make it work in the medical
field and give information about Islam
to people who want you no need to know
like that and to work in the field of
Dawa
yes each people about this religion yes
what is good about this religion you're
13 years old you're not adult yet you're
in the in the process of being adult
yeah tell me what what what attracts you
would do this religion that you know
that there is an afterlife that would be
greater then yeah but it has another
life and death love of Allah
look some people and that's kinda what
though I mean you love Allah support I'm
I'm not a lot myself and this is where
you get the comfort to your heart yes
you feel comfortable by belonging to
this religion mhm right Michele I'm
proud of you to hear that and again and
again
tell me something that do you when you
pray how can you pray are you sit in my
chair sit in your chair and do it like
any other okay you put your hand on your
chin yes as possible anyone who invent
obray you've been over yes yes so you do
exactly the prayer as if I are
travelling but it's sitting there
sitting because when we are travelling
in an airplane for example we sit on
chairs and we do exactly as you said yes
we put our hands like this and we start
reciting then we bow a little bit then
without more and we finish them yes
again and again and again I remind
everybody who is sick showing us Muslims
and non-muslims he is an example of a
person who is disabled even though he
does not miss his prayer he does the
prayer as the prophet sallallaahu your
Selim asked us to do if you cannot do it
while you are standing you can do it
while you are sitting there is no excuse
for the people to not to do the prayer I
want everybody to learn from this
experience and shame on us if we have
all the organs in our bodies and all our
limbs
in our bodies and we don't perform our
prayers see this is an example a true
example the first time for me to meet
him and okay now I'd like you to to hear
from you a word for your parents are
wonderful parents your father who's
sitting here I'm so sorry because I
cannot communicate with him I don't know
sign language I wish I would have
learned this what would you like to tell
your father that I love homeland
I'm thankful for my Luke to you know
help me and teach me everything that you
need to know you love your father you
thank you for helping you and for
teaching you you're enjoying your life
with him and you told me that you have
some fun and some good time with your
sisters yes do you have the same time
with your father and yes play around and
I'm gonna laugh with each other okay and
the school that you go and you spend how
many times do you go to school do you go
every day yes I go every day tell me
about do you enjoy the environment yes I
enjoy cuz everybody it's from a
different culture and okay you get to
learn and the people are really nice
they're good wonderful did you have a
chance to to talk to some people about
Islam and your presentations or in your
discussions at school well yeah like my
um aide who helps me yes you know he
didn't know that what some so I told him
and he learned a little he learned a lot
of Islam your aid the one which gives
you support yes at school yes you taught
him about Islam yes yes and he's happy
about it yeah and he believes that that
the media talks negatively about the
Islam the media isn't fair to Islam and
you're giving him a clearer picture of
Islam which the essence of it is peace
which which we hope that everybody would
enjoy peace in the whole world yes
that's wonderful thing okay now you are
in the Deen show and
you ever seen some programs on the Dean
show yes I've seen some with the little
girl yes and hung rapper Lulu and have
you seen yes okay okay
why do you watch the danger
because it Sam it's nice to know that
like there's um
other Muslims who show how they live and
you know and it gives a real message of
Islam to people to the Muslims and
non-muslims yes and I think that it's a
good way of saying that this is this is
our Islam this is the mainstream and
we're trying to present as much as
possible the image of our beloved
prophet what's his name
well it's know how much I love yourself
this again this is a great opportunity i
thank allah subhanaw taala
for giving me this opportunity but
before I leave you I wish I don't want
to leave you I want to stay with you
longer time but I ask Almighty Allah to
give you quick recovery and to give you
a little back insha'Allah very soon and
we'd see you playing with us we'll come
and play with your Chihuahua and if it
doesn't happen I hope it happens very
soon Chawla but I'm quite sure that
Allah SWA no data will give you a much
better life in later life you're sure of
that yes I'm glad to meet you and I'm
gonna kiss your hand if you allow me
yeah Lost Planet Allah bless you and
bless your family and I'm thankful to
the DNC who gave me this opportunity to
interview sanim again I want you to
remember this wonderful name and I hope
I don't forget it or Salam alaikum
warahmatullah over a capital this is
your host doctor when your florentine
muhammad OBU would submit to him avoid
the danger of the major sins obey avoid
to him avoid the danger of the major
sins ope o Lord surrender to him
avoid the danger of the major sins obey
your Lord
submit to him mercy on us older Souls
avoid the footsteps of Shaitan who's
plotting scheme in 24/7 trickery
deception falsehood lies anything to
keep you in the firing line he'll tell
you anything that you wanna hear you'll
be your friend when no one else is there
no matter what he says he's a stone-cold
liar he only wants to keep you in the
fire and stay away all the whispers
can mercy on us all we see away all the
whispers
[Music]